ya tenemos las herramientas necesarias
para factorizar este binomio x cuadrada
más 4 x menos 5 y básicamente lo que
hacemos es buscar dos números que cuando
los multiplicamos nos quede menos 5 pero
que cuando lo sumemos nos quede 4
entonces lo que hacemos es tomar este
número y escribir todos sus factores en
este caso estamos tratando con un número
primo entonces va a tener simplemente
dos factores los cuales son 1 y 5 porque
es un número primo y por aquí como
tenemos aquí menos 5 entonces sabemos
que uno de estos dos números es negativo
y el otro positivo entonces en realidad
tenemos a la pareja de números menos 1 y
5 esa es una de las parejas y la única
otra pareja es 1
y -5 que hay pero de hecho esta pareja
es la que funciona porque menos uno por
cinco si es menos cinco pero además
menos 15 es 4 entonces utilizando las
herramientas que ya conocemos esta
expresión es igual a x menos 1
por x + 5 aunque sabes que déjame usar
colores para que se vea más bonito y
porque puede ayudar a entender algunas
cosas más adelante en este vídeo
entonces a este menos uno lo vamos a
pintar de rosa
y a este 5 lo vamos a pintar de azul y
podemos aquí rápidamente verificar que
esta multiplicación de binomios si nos
da esta expresión tenemos aquí x por x
nos da x cuadrada y después menos x nos
queda una menos x pero luego por aquí
tenemos más 5 x x entonces tenemos más 5
x menos una x y entonces si nos queda 4x
y finalmente menos 1 por 5 menos 5
entonces estas dos expresiones si son
iguales bueno pero ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es mucho más interesante que esto
de aquí fue simplemente un repaso de
algo que ya no sabemos perfectamente
ahora vamos a creer factorizar x
cuadrada
4x y menos 5 de cuadrada y te recomiendo
que lo pongas pausa en este momento del
vídeo y trates de resolverlo tú por tu
cuenta antes de que yo te dé aquí la
solución el truco está en este término
aquí escribimos 4x porque y pues esa es
la convención mundial del orden en el
que se escriben las variables
pero pues estamos haciendo una
multiplicación entonces aplica la
conjunta actividad y entonces este
término es igualito al término 4 y equis
este término es exactamente igual a
escribir x cuadrada más 4 y x menos 5 de
cuadrada ahora esta es la forma en que
se escriben los polinomios que han
únicamente para que se vean más bonitos
y todos entiendan mejor lo que estás
diciendo pero esta forma de escribir al
mismo polinomio en este caso nos ayuda
más porque si lo escribimos de esta
forma entonces podemos pensar a 4 y
podemos pensar en este término como el
coeficiente de esta x en esta ecuación
sería correspondiente a este coeficiente
de esta variable x y de este lado todo
este término de aquí es equivalente a
este término de aquí aunque esto me muy
complicado ya con dos variables con una
x aquí al cuadrado y todo pero en el
fondo son exactamente la misma cosa y se
resuelven de la misma manera que tenemos
x cuadrada más un coeficiente por x más
otro término que no depende de x
entonces lo que vamos a hacer es buscar
dos términos y en este caso van a ser
términos que contienen variables y no
simplemente números como estos números
de aquí entonces buscamos dos términos
que multiplicarnos nos dé menos 5 porque
cuadrada pero que a la hora de sumar nos
nos dé simplemente 4 y
entonces pensemos en expresiones en
términos que si los multiplicamos nos
quedan menos 5 y cuadrada vamos a
ponerle por aquí y por menos 5 y si
multiplicamos por menos 5 que nos queda
menos 5 de cuadrada muy bien entonces
ahora vamos a ver si lo sumamos nos
queda 4 y menos 5 y más nos queda menos
4 y bueno estuvimos muy cerca pero
necesitamos que sean más 4 y en lugar de
menos 4 y así es que vamos a ver si
funciona cambiar el signo de este
término a este término aunque tenemos
por aquí un menos entonces sabemos que
va a haber un término que sí tenga signo
menos y otro término que no tenga signo
menos
ok entonces cambiamos el signo del lugar
y nos queda menos
5 y a ver si funciona menos por cinco es
menos cinco cuadrada muy bien y por otro
lado cinco y menos y eso sí es cuatro y
entonces esta pareja de expresiones es
la que queremos vamos a ponerle
colorcito 2 para que sea más fácil ver a
dónde van a dar y este 5 y vamos a
ponerlo de azul ok entonces ya tenemos
dos expresiones que si los multiplicamos
nos da el término que no depende de x y
si las sumamos nos da el coeficiente de
x así es que vamos a aplicar exactamente
la misma técnica que ya conocíamos para
expresiones cuadráticas con una sola
variable que vamos a poner por aquí
x menos ya que es uno de los términos y
eso tiene que ser x x más el otro
término nada 5 y ok entonces yo afirmo
que esta multiplicación de estos dos
binomios es exactamente igual a este
polinomio pero pues todo lo que hacemos
lo tenemos que verificar así es que
vamos a verificarlo haciendo la
multiplicación de estos dos binomios
y vamos a multiplicar este por este y
nos queda x cuadrada y ahora vamos a
multiplicar este
y nos queda más 5 g por x ahora
multiplicamos este por este nos queda
menos y por equis y finalmente nada más
nos falta multiplicar este por este y
nos queda menos 5 cuadrada y ya de aquí
lo único que nos falta es agrupar los
términos para que veas que realmente es
este mismo polinomio entonces 5 x menos
por x pues aquí tenemos 5 de esta cosa
que es que por equis y le queremos
restar 1 de esta cosa que es por equis
entonces cinco menos uno nos queda
simplemente cuatro de jeff por equis
pero ye por equis es exactamente lo
mismo que x porque entonces tenemos por
aquí 4x y nada más tenemos que incluir
al resto de los términos
y aquí tenemos a equis y listo este
polinomio ya se ve muy claramente que es
igual a este polinomio pero pues este
polinomio es simplemente lo que nos
queda de multiplicar estos dos binomios